jessica
is in canada hi jessica how are you
hi dave and rachel thank you for taking
my call
i'm currently on baby step number two
i'm 60 000
in debt um i recently started listening
to you so i'm being intentional i'm
going at it gazillion times and i've
paid off twelve thousand dollars so far
nice um thanks so i grew up with a very
unstable home
when it comes to money my mother is a
very big spender and she
never ever had enough money for the
month
while i don't blame anyone else but
myself for my bad financial decisions
she's the ones who sort of pushed me or
guided me in the direction to make poor
financial decisions and
all my debt i have is credit cards and
loans so
now that i'm being very frugal she
thinks i'm completely crazy
and she was pushing me to file for
bankruptcy and
every time i see her it's a constant
battle because was
on different pages and i i can't seem to
make her understand
that what she's teaching is wrong and
what she's doing is wrong
so i wanted to know your input on how to
approach that situation
how old are you jessica i'm 28 28 okay
well the hard part about the relational
aspect of money
is that some people just don't
understand and the hard thing is you
can't control them
to force them to see that they are wrong
so i would say on her end and unless
she's asking
and wanting to learn i wouldn't push
you know your your stuff on her because
she's she's not asking and
you talking about it unless it's
celebratory and you're like hey mom i
just paid this off and i'm excited
and you have that kind of conversation
knowing that it's probably not going to
she's
not gonna have the best response i would
probably just
leave finances out of the discussion if
she keeps bringing it up
then there needs to be a boundary put in
place because it's not worth the strain
on your relationship you're doing
something
that is wise with your money and you're
going down this journey
she doesn't agree and so being able to
put up a boundary
and say hey mom since you keep bringing
it up this is what i'm doing i'm 28
years old
this is why i'm doing this because i
want stability i want peace i want money
in the bank and
you can get various reasons why and say
and if you don't understand that's okay
but i need your respect enough
for me not to negatively
keep talking to me do you mean just
having that sometimes you have to just
have a boundary that says
we can't talk about this subject because
if we are going to talk about this
subject
we are not going to do well and i'd
rather i'd rather do well i'd rather
have the relationship
for instance i have a relative that
votes wrong
they just vote for the wrong people
every time they have
a knack for it and um and they blindly
vote for one party
regardless and um so
uh which i have no use for voting wrong
or voting for the wrong party regardless
or voting for a party regardless
no matter what i vote for that party no
that's just ridiculous
and so um but i love them
and what i have figured out is is
they're not going to change
and so just constantly berating them
about it is not going to help
and talking to them about it is not
going to help because it makes me mad
so the best thing to do is just not talk
about
politics with that relative because
they're just wrong
you know and that's kind of what you may
have to do with your mom is just like
mom i can't talk about money with you
because you and i don't agree on this
and we're just going to find something
else to talk about because we love each
other
and it's just that's you know how's the
weather uh how about them titans
i mean you know i mean it's just you
know it's just
how about the football team you know i
mean you can't find something else and
you
put that boundary in place like rachel's
saying but it's
very difficult to do um and you know
probably the most difficult boundary is
mother to grown daughter that is one of
the more difficult relationship
boundaries because both are relationship
animals
and they feel entitled they feel like
they have rights
to speak into each other's lives
uh and so they don't you know sometimes
they just don't do well with it and it's
okay to set some boundaries in place
and jessica i would say for you i mean i
heard a little bit of your tone and and
the way you even framed up the question
that there's a little bit of hurt
and resentment towards your mom i mean
you said the way i handle money today is
because of what i learned from her and
i'm just
in a terrible spot because of it and so
there is this this interesting dynamic
now that you are a grown adult and
you're working through oh wow
my mom you know did things in my
childhood that i don't agree with
and now because that's how i was raised
i almost just didn't even know to do any
better so that's how you got to this
place
i'm glad you're changing everything
because there's a rule jessica and the
rule is once you're 30 you can't blame
your parents anymore okay you always say
that i don't agree
it's not that i put blame but there is
real hurts and things that go on no i
know
i know but you can't blame them you can
have you can be hurt yes you can
here's my quote i love this quote when
it comes to talking about your parents
you're not here to bash them
and i heard a little bit right like oh
right here to bash them we're not here
to defend them we're here to tell the
truth
so tell the truth jessica like tell the
truth of of what you experience
and then learn from that and grow and so
i think both of the other ends
extreme are unhealthy because you're not
getting to the root emotion of your mom
so there's a relational aspect there too
jessica i would really dig into and if
there's a level of hurt and resentment
you may
talk to someone about that i mean
there's i think all of that is very
healthy yeah
i don't disagree you always say that
once you're 30 you can't blame your
parents well you can't
you can't it's not you're
you just don't like the statement but
awareness that once you're past 30
you can still have hurt from your
parents you can say i've heard but you
can't blame him but i'm not speaking out
of experience
he has never ever done anything
yeah look oh yeah we should start a new
radio show yeah i would just start a new
one here
confessions confessions of the rams the
uh uh
so there's a difference there's a
difference in hurt and blame though
all right dr john deloney tell me well
you can still have you can you can be
hurt yes and admit that there's a wound
there
yes but you can no longer uh let that be
the reason that you're not winning yes
100 that's what i mean you can't blame
them
100 it's not blame is it's someone
else's fault i'm not winning
yes and that is not is not no it's not
your parent's fault you're not winning
once you're 30. it's your fault
i don't know why i keep saying 30. it's
just well i just made it up
it's not it's not a scientific fact it's
just a davis
all right guys she's got 28 she's got
two years to go she's still okay
oh good yeah just gonna get you got
plenty of time jessica you're gonna make
it
oh